Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight,
the American Dream continues.
What?
Let's get down
to business, folks.
Are you not open
for negotiations?
It's called the shark tank
for a reason.
What you're missing
is the consumer.
Well, I'm not missing 'em.
Are you kidding me?
Oh.
Ooh.
Snow White always
talked to animals,
and they never had
the ability to talk back.
I'm right there with ya.
Silence, please.
You are so rude.
So, who's ready to turn
this flow into dough?
You can end this!
Just buy my product!
You can end it!
‐No!
‐Damn, this is good.
♪♪
‐Hey!
‐Come on in!
Smells like
fish fry to me.
My family's from
New Orleans.
Being from New Orleans,
we're lovers of seafood.
As a matter of fact, no other
food group existed to me.
You ready?
Yeah!
What makes my seafood
so good,
it's the gourmet
herbs and spices
that gives me
my secret recipe.
You got to try it.
Here you go.
Joe: We were in New Orleans
when Katrina hit.
We had two
restaurants there.
And, all in one day,
everything changed.
Everything was lost.
All that survived
were two fryers.
Me and my dad hit the road
all across the country.
Boy, this is good.
This is good?
This is the one
right here.
My dad heavily invested
in our business.
He gave me
his entire retirement.
Him and my mom
sold their house,
and have been immersed
in this business since.
We are all in ‐‐
financially, spiritually.
Everything is riding
on Joe's.
And we wouldn't have it
any other way.
We wouldn't.
♪♪
Hi.
I'm Joe Dowell.
And I'm his wife
Maranda Dowell.
And we're here
from Atlanta, Georgia,
seeking an investment
of $150,000
for a 15% stake
in our company,
Joe's Gourmet Fish Fry.
We are here to introduce
you to a product
that will change the way
you eat seafood forever.
Now anyone can make the
best‐tasting seafood at home,
with Joe's Gourmet
Fish Fry.
It is a delicious,
all‐in‐one seafood breading mix
that's crushing
any other breading mix.
And it's not just
for seafood.
You can bake
or air‐fry with it.
You want crispy‐fried
chicken?
Mm‐hmm.
Yeah.
Try Joe's.
How about savory,
fried green tomatoes?
Try Joe's.
Hmm.
Scrumptious crabcakes,
anyone?
I'll take one.
Try Joe's.
Maranda: Over the years,
we have one simple truth.
When people try it...
...Oh, they gonna buy it!
[ Laughter ]
With that being said,
who's ready to try it?
Oh, we got to try it!
‐Buy it.
‐Definitely.
And have the whole
world experience
their own
emotional reaction
to Joe's Gourmet Fish Fry.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, let's get
to the samples.
You got us so excited!
Let's get down
to business, folks.
Okay.
Try this.
This is the real deal.
What you're about to taste
is the truth, folks.
What we got here
is just to show you
how versatile
the breading is.
Thank you.
We have shrimp,
some zucchini,
a piece of halibut,
even a scallop.
Oh my God, the chicken
is fantastic.
Greiner: Ooh.
I do like it.
Oh yes, that's the ‐‐ that's
what we were waiting on.
That right there.
Mmm.
‐The shrimp is so good.
‐You complete me.
‐Really good.
‐Mmm, it is amazing.
‐Can we see the bags?
‐Can we get some bags?
‐Absolutely.
So, it's called "Fish Fry"
but you applied it
to both vegetables and ‐‐
Anything you
can fry, right?
Anything ‐‐ and it's
on the packaging ‐‐
the different applications
you can use it on.
Or you could add
"not just" Fish Fry.
‐There you go.
‐Absolutely.
Okay.
What are your numbers?
One bag costs us
$1.22 to make.
We sell it directly
to the consumer for $5.
When we sell it to a wholesaler,
it's from $2.25 to $2.75,
and our retailers sell it
anywhere from $2.99 to $4.25.
What are your lifetime
sales to date?
We've sold $409,000
worth of product.
‐That's really great.
‐And this year ‐‐
what do you think
you'll do this year?
This year, we're going to
finish out at about $270,000,
and next year
we're projecting $450,000.
‐Good for you.
‐And the reason being
we've only been
in Wal‐Mart.
This is our
seventh week, guys.
‐Yeah. Oh, wow.
‐And the sales are climbing.
We're super‐excited.
John: And have you done
any on‐site?
Absolutely.
You've done on premise?
That is what we do.
Every week you will find us
selling somewhere.
We go out there with three
palettes of our product,
and we don't leave
until it's sold.
‐You still do that today?
‐That's clever.
Absolutely.
We still do it.
Every week.
Herjavec: How did you and
Maranda come up with this?
Well, I'm just a blue‐collar
worker, you know.
I started off ‐‐
No such thing as "just".
‐Nothing wrong with that.
‐Yeah, there you go.
I started off in manufacturing,
but I found my passion
when I started
waiting tables.
You know, I enjoyed
serving others,
so I saved up my money,
called my dad,
and said,
"Hey, I got a great idea.
Why don't you give me
all of your money?"
And surprisingly,
he did.
He did.
And, so, we went into business,
opened up my first restaurant,
and that's where I met
this lovely young lady.
Yes, so we met the first time
in one of his restaurants.
I went in to sell him
some advertising.
But the funny story is,
you guys,
as soon as I walked
into this restaurant,
I met him.
He said, "You know what?
I think you're the woman
I'm going to marry".
Aww.
I didn't see him again
for eight years after that.
No!
Seriously.
I saw him on the corner,
in this little tent
that you see on the bag,
with his dad.
Joe: The other Joe.
Selling these fish plates,
and he walks up to my car,
and he says,
"Are you married?"
And I'm like, "No".
And he said, "You know what?
You're about to be".
And two weeks later,
I had this ring on my finger.
No!
Yes.
Yeah!
John:
So, guys, how long were you
doing the business ‐‐
the restaurant business?
Well, the restaurant's
done very well.
We ended up opening up
six restaurants.
Okay. That's good.
‐Wow.
They still going?
Absolutely not.
Oh.
Ooh.
Well, being from New Orleans,
Katrina hit,
and kind of shut
everything done.
Oh, my God.
But the only thing
that was saved in there,
I had these two fryers
that was in storage,
so I took a tent,
grabbed those two fryers,
and I went to any festival,
any concert
from Chicago to Miami,
and everything in‐between,
selling this finished product.
And how long were
you doing that ‐‐
just hitting the streets?
That was about
15 years.
Yeah, about 15 years.
15 years of hitting
the corner?
I got some fryers
in the car right now.
I'm still frying fish.
Sorry, Joe, were you selling
the product in grocery stores,
or were you just
driving around to festivals,
frying food and selling it?
So, I'll tell you
how that happened.
One day, I went out
to the festival.
He had a line of people
wanting food in the front,
but then he had people with,
like, Tupperware and baggies,
and he's like, "I don't have
time for those people.
They want to take it home,
and they want to fry it
themselves,
and I'm trying to make
some money out here".
Yeah. Yeah.
And the light bulb
went off.
And I said, "Dude,
this is our business.
Let's bag it and sell it".
How long ago was that,
Maranda?
This is our third year.
So, I went out to our little,
local grocery store.
They've got about
eight locations,
and it just
started selling.
Is this still
New Orleans?
We're in ‐‐
We live in Atlanta now.
Now, okay.
So, basically, since
those eight stores,
we're now in 800 stores.
We're in 315
Wal‐Mart stores.
We're going into
52 Kroger stores.
‐Wow.
‐We're in 142 Publix...
‐Fantastic.
‐Wow.
...Meijer and ATB.
And that is really
hard to do.
Alright, how much of your money
do you have invested
in this business?
Um, It's a total of $50,000
from the family.
Well, my dad
owns 80 ‐‐
85.
85%.
What?
But ‐‐ But here's
the deal, guys.
We are a very
strong‐knit family.
If you knew me back in the day,
my credit was zero.
I'm right there with you.
So ‐‐
Same here.
In order to get this thing
rolling, he was our front guy.
Alright, guys.
I'm just looking at it,
and saying to myself,
"Okay,
how do I get there
as an investor?"
You asked me for 15% here,
for $150,000.
That imputes
a million‐dollar value.
Yes.
Okay.
As an investor,
how many times
am I paying to get
to that million value?
25 times.
There are no food companies
on the planet Earth
trading at a 25‐multiple
for fish fry, okay?
Well, let me
tell you this.
What your missing
is the consumer.
Well, I'm not missing 'em.
This is how all ‐‐
like you say,
your little soldiers,
your money‐soldiers.
Yeah, yeah.
This is how ‐‐
I don't want them to die.
They're all dead.
I want them to come back with
prisoners, you know that.
So, listen ‐‐
so the consumer is this.
That's where our
expertise is.
Well, Joe Jr., you're not worth
a million bucks, buddy.
I'm sorry.
Are you kidding me?
You'd be making
a great bet, Kevin.
Absolutely.
To give you $150,000,
I'd have to get about
50% of your business.
That's what it's worth today.
I'm not saying you won't
grow it, but I'm out.
Well, I'm going to share
with you my thoughts.
For me, it tasted fabulous.
But not every business, to me,
is right for an investor.
I think you're doing great,
I think you're
an amazing salesperson,
and you're killing it
at the fairs,
but I wouldn't feel
good investing,
and for that reason, I'm out.
Thank you.
Alright.
Cuban: Okay, so kind of
from my perspective,
it's got to be a product
that not just that I love,
but I can demonstrate.
My idea of cooking
is taking a hot dog,
wrapping it in a paper towel,
and putting it in the microwave,
and saying,
"Damn, this is good".
Right.
It's just not a product
that really fits who I am,
so I'm out,
but I congratulate you.
Thank you.
You guys grind,
you guys hustle.
You are a perfect example of ‐‐
if an entrepreneur
is relentless,
anything is possible.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Herjavec: You know, to Mark's
point ‐‐ I love you, guys.
You're smiling. We're throwing
a lot of stuff at you.
Here's what I don't know ‐‐
how do I invest $150,000
when your dad owns 85% of it?
Well, he has given all authority
to Joe to make the decisions.
Absolutely.
I can't make you an offer
under which
you're still going
to be smiling.
I just can't.
You could try, Robert.
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Robert likes Maranda and Joe's
fish breading product,
Joe's Gourmet Fish Fry,
but is unsure about an offer.
Herjavec: Alright, guys.
I can't make you an offer
under which
you're still going
to be smiling.
I‐I just can't.
You could try,
Robert.
I can't do it.
I'm out.
But you still have
one shark left.
And then
there was one.
I think we've all been wrestling
with a couple of things here.
Yes, the valuation,
but here's why I love you ‐‐
you're standing on corners,
and when you stand on corners,
you are getting paid
to have a focus group,
you know what your customers
like and don't like.
Yeah.
I stood on corners eight years
trying to sell my hats,
and when you stand on the corner
of the Apollo Theater
trying to sell a hat
in the middle of Harlem‐‐
That's it.
They tell you what they think
about your hat and your mama.
You know it.
You know them.
So, I get it.
I've got an offer for you.
$150,000 for 25%.
‐Say "Yes".
‐Say "Yes" to that deal.
That's a good one.
Say "Yes".
♪♪
18% and you
have a deal.
No!
We'll do 25%.
Alright.
You got a deal, Day.
I just tried it
and guess what I did?!
I'd like to buy it, baby!
There you go!
Appreciate it.
Thank you!
Alright!
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, guys.
We're gonna make
so much money!
‐Look at that!
‐Over here, Day.
So, Maranda, you just sold
Fish Fry for $600,000 valuation.
Now that is selling.
Maranda: A deal with Daymond
is amazing.
He went all‐in, and we
are so grateful for it.
Narrator:
In Season 7, Dave Vasen made
a deal with Mark Cuban
and Chris Sacca
for brightwheel,
an online platform that
helps early educators
connect with families.
Let's see how they're doing now.
Vasen: Before "Shark Tank",
brightwheel was being used
in 2,500 schools in the U. S.
After "Shark Tank", it's more
than 25,000 across the globe.
Brightwheel is the all‐in‐one
solution for early education,
so schools can manage everything
from staff to their billing,
and parents can actually
stay connected
to their kids
throughout the day.
We launched the free app
to prove the concept.
Now, we launched
a brand‐new version
called brightwheel premium,
adding things like
staff management,
two‐way messaging,
and parents are able to sign in
from their own phone.
Today, Mark and Chris
are joining me
for a really important meeting
with the Learning Care Group,
the second largest for‐profit
childcare provider
in North America.
They have been testing out
the premium version
of brightwheel
in one of their schools.
Our families are
absolutely loving it,
so we're prepared
to roll with you guys
on a three‐year,
million‐plus deal.
Learning Care Group
offered a multi‐year deal
to all 100 centers,
20,000 teachers, hundreds
of thousands of parents,
and they want
to do it right away.
When I came in to "Shark Tank",
our company had zero revenue,
and in just a few months since
launching brightwheel premium,
we now booked over $2,000,000
in sales for this year.
Seeing it here in the flesh,
seeing the money behind
a deal like this ‐‐
it's all coming true.
Sacca: When you think about
how brightwheel
has revolutionized
the way schools do business,
and the way teachers
interact with parents,
there's really no limit
to how big this can get.
And I'm convinced this might be
one of the biggest deals
"Shark Tank" has ever seen.
Let's shoot
a brightwheel video.
That's such good idea.
Yeah, let's do it.
I'm a Shark, but I'm also a dad,
and I know how important
early education is.
Now with brightwheel, we can
impact the early education
of tens of millions of children
across this country.
That's incredible,
and, you know,
that's the beauty of
"Shark Tank".
Brightwheel!
Narrator:
Next up is a product that
gives voice to the voiceless.
♪♪
Winowich: Hi, Sharks.
My name is Princess
Michelle Winowich
from Bloomfield Hills, Michigan.
I am the prouder founder
of G. O. A. T. Pet Products.
We're here today seeking
a G. O. A. T partner
to invest $499,000
in exchange for 9%‐equity
in our company.
[ Laughter ]
Whew.
Pet lovers have
all shared the dream
of wishing their
pets could talk,
just like in fairy tales.
Now, what if I told you
that I have the power
to give your pet a voice?
Meet Axel, a retired canine
hero that can speak.
Isn't that right, Axel?
Axel: That's right,
Princess Michelle!
Canine Axel, reporting for duty!
What?
Sharks, I'm not
really a princess,
and Axel here isn't really
a magical talking dog.
He's the proud owner
of our G. O. A. T.
Pet Speaker, and our
one‐of‐a‐kind app
that gives you the ability
to interact with your pet
like never before.
Axel: You're so right,
Michelle.
But in addition to
giving me a voice,
the G. O. A. T. Pet Speaker
does so much more, like ‐‐
I'll take it from here,
Axel, but thank you.
Not only does the G. O. A. T. Pet
Speaker give your pet a voice,
you can also stream your
favorite tunes out on walks.
What?
♪ So dream on,
dream on, dream on ♪
Or to help relieve pet anxiety,
you can stream calming,
soothing classical music.
[ Tchaikovsky's
"The Garland Waltz" plays ]
[ Laughs ]
And with a built‐in selfie
remote button,
right on the bottom
of the speaker,
now you can be in the picture
with your best friend.
Say "cheese."
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
As you can see, Sharks, G. O. A. T.
Pet Products is on track
to be the greatest of all time
in the pet industry,
but I'm here because
I need your partnership
to make my fairy tale a reality.
Michelle, before
I figure out
if you're on a sabbatical
from Bellevue,
why are you dressed
like Snow White?
Snow White always
talked to animals,
and they never had
the ability to talk back.
Have you talked to Snow White,
or the animals to find that out?
It's in the fairy tale.
In the fairy tale.
O'Leary:
Michelle, is there a reason
you would have spent time
making this product?
What made you want to do it?
So, can I pass out some samples?
Can I have you take
a look at it?
Wow, what a beautiful dog.
Fairy tale packaging.
Thank you.
It's ‐‐ I did bring an extra
treat for Mr. Wonderful.
‐Do I get the apple, too?
‐Poisoned apple?
He's not going to
rip us to shreds
if we don't do
a deal, is he?
Well, we do have
a secret command for that.
Thank you.
Greiner: They're very
cute‐looking.
I'm still not quite sure
what they do ‐‐
Okay.
But they look cute.
So, basically, the app
lets me record things
that I want my dog
to say to me?
Correct.
So, I could create
a dialogue‐‐
I love you, Kevin.
No, it could be "Pick it
up yourself", or it could be,
"I'm going to pee
on the fire hydrant now".
Well, Michelle, you have
a $5,000,000‐valuation.
No problem there,
Robert.
No, no, no.
This thing
makes dogs talk.
"That's cheap, Robert".
Obviously, if you have
a $5,000,000‐valuation ‐‐
Mm‐hmm?
You sold a lot of
talking dog units.
The G. O. A. T.
Pet Speaker.
Why G. O. A. T.?
Greatest Of All Time.
And your sales are?
We've had over $2,000,000 in
sales in less than six months.
‐What?
‐What?!
You sold $2,000,000
of this crap?
‐This is incredible!
‐Don't say "crap"!
You look amazing
in that outfit now.
Thank you.
How?!
My experience is from
the pet industry.
I've launched many brands,
as a brand manager,
as a national sales manager.
I had a great job,
making $100,000 a year,
and full of ideas
for new products,
but I came home one night
and I told my husband
about this idea
that I was going to tell my boss
the next day, and he was like,
"Why do we keep paying
for everybody else's kids
to go to college?"
Like, "Just save these ideas,
like stop".
And so, I did, and a family
friend offered to partner,
basically, as an investor,
so I immediately
put in my notice,
I quit my job ‐‐
‐Wait a minute.
I'm curious, like ‐‐
I don't think I understand
why it was such a big hit.
Winowich: When I went to Global
Pet Expo to launch this,
people literally, without
exaggerating,
were lining up to see.
I've been to these
trade shows ‐‐
Did you get
orders there?
I did. I wrote more orders
than I have in 10 years
on my first day.
Okay. Okay. And then you
fulfilled those orders ‐‐
No.
No?
Because ‐‐ Because then,
I saw PetSmart.
And they said that they were
extremely interested,
but they like exclusivity.
How long were they going
to be exclusive?
Six months.
Did you give
them that?
Yes.
‐What did they buy?
How much did they buy?
They bought over
$2,000,000‐worth.
Wow.
It's incredible.
Is it $2,000,000 that is going
to hit the store,
and then you're going
to see the sell‐through,
but that's
the initial order?
Correct.
We don't know if they're
going to sell‐through.
‐Do you have to take returns?
‐There is no returns.
They can't return anything?
No, that was part of
the negotiations
for me to give up
exclusivity.
Okay, how much are they?
What do you sell these for?
$24.99.
$24.99, right.
Your cost‐to‐make is...
Um, my cost‐to‐make is
under $5, and that's ‐‐.
Landed?
Landed costs, including
packaging, everything.
Okay.
So, how much money did you raise
from your silent partner?
To date, $260,000.
And how much equity
did he get for that?
50%.
‐Ooh.
‐50%?
50?
Yes, but
I needed a million dollars
in inventory, quick.
Alright. Look, it's the scariest
place, where you are right now.
If it doesn't start selling
right away at
this price point ‐‐
Right.
You are screwed.
But I'm not,
and I'll tell you why.
Because ‐‐
She's getting paid.
But that's no good.
You'll never sell again.
No.
Whatever it is that I needed
to support it, I would.
And I'm educating all
the store managers ‐‐
I'm an investor.
You're asking me to value
you at $5,500,000
and give you $499,000.
And I have no data as to whether
or not this will sell.
I just ‐‐ and you can't
give it to me.
I'm trying to figure out how to
invest in something like this
with a pragmatic,
financial discipline,
because you're not
worth $5,500,000
until you can show me
it sells through,
and they give you three
more orders like that,
and maybe that'll happen.
But there's no way for me
to find out.
There's no way to structure
a deal that makes sense.
They're putting huge
support behind it,
because they're backing it.
No, you're mistaken.
I think you're ‐‐
you‐‐you're missing his point.
With your orders that you're
creating with 200,000 units,
you're creating $1,000,000
in gross margin dollars ‐‐
right? ‐‐
for this one sale,
which is great, right?
Right.
But you're valuing the company
as if that's going to be
repeating on an
ongoing basis, right?
Yes.
And that's what
we don't know yet.
But here's the other part.
I hate the pet industry.
I don't have a feel for
what's going to last,
and what's not
going to last.
I just don't get
that industry.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay, then.
Let me just say, "I'm out".
Michelle, I am shocked that
they gave an order that big
because it's an enormous risk
for them on something
that is not tested or proved.
This is not something
that I could invest in,
and at that valuation,
it's even further beyond.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Okay, now, you created this
company for what reason?
Because you were tired of
making everybody else rich.
You gave away 50% of your
company at a very early stage.
That means, for me
to give you anything,
I'm going to have to give you
a very aggressive offer,
which I'm not
ready to do,
because I don't
want you to go back
to the situation that
you left, so I'm out.
Thank you.
Robert, what are you
going to do?
Well, there's only
one shark left.
And it's you.
In nine years, I've patted dogs,
I've eaten dog food.
I've watched every time.
I've licked cats,
I even dropped a dog once,
but you've done something
no one's ever done
that's come out here, you got
a single order for $2,000,000.
It's incredible.
We don't really know
where it's going to go,
but I love it,
and I love this industry.
And?
I'm going to make you
an aggressive offer.
Narrator: Four Sharks are out,
but Robert seems interested
in Michelle's pet speaker
company, G. O. A. T.
Herjavec: We don't really know
where it's going to go,
but I love it,
and I love this industry.
And?
I'm going to make you
an aggressive offer.
I'll give you the $499,000
for one‐third.
I understand you have orders,
and they're fantastic.
But we don't really know
if it's going to sell through.
So, you were at 9%.
Correct.
And he wants 33%.
So, obviously, I came here
to negotiate, not just to be ‐‐
I‐I don't want
to negotiate.
I don't want to waste your time,
because I know you have
to go back to the dwarves.
You can choose
to accept it, or not.
So, you're not open
to negotiations?
You wouldn't consider 20%?
No.
It's ‐‐ It's one‐third.
$499,000 for 33%.
For 33%.
One‐third.
"One‐third".
I just want to negotiate.
You're not letting me.
So, you wouldn't
consider not even 25%?
You know, Michelle,
you could counter.
I‐I'm going to say "No".
I'm going to tell you
that right now.
$500,000 is a lot
of money.
Mm‐hmm.
And so, I want to have
the level of risk...
Sure.
...that I feel comfortable
with that at best.
Sure. Direct sales ‐‐
I'm not going
to change my offer.
We have a profit
margin of 89%.
‐The real question is ‐‐
‐Okay.
Michelle,
you asked for $499,000.
That's a lot of money.
You have to decide ‐‐
what do you want to do?
Are you going to give up
33 1/3% of your company?
That's one‐third.
Or not?
He's not flexible.
Are you?
It's called "the Shark Tank"
for a reason.
What do you want to do?
To me, the natural next step
is to partner with you.
So, I'd absolutely love
to take your offer.
Done! Great.
‐Wow.
Perfect. Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
Cheers.
Thank you.
Thank you!
You guys, thank you
very much.
Congratulations.
It's a lot of late nights
and some all‐nighters,
and it's ‐‐ it was to get me
to this point,
to be able to say
that Robert is my partner,
so it is beyond
a dream come true.
Robert, if it's a bust you'll
never get your $499,000 back.
Ever.
Herjavec:
We'll find out,
and I think that dog
wanted to eat you.
I programmed it.
Right now,
it's swearing
at her out there
for selling a third
of the company.
[ Laughs ]
Narrator: Next into the tank
is a way to look presentable
and comfortable.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Howie Busch,
and I'm from Long Island,
New York.
I'm seeking $150,000 in exchange
for 18% of my company,
DudeRobe.
Sharks, I have
a confession to make.
I'm not a robe guy.
Never have been.
That's because robes
for guys kind of suck.
For one, I just wouldn't want
anyone to see me like this.
Whether you're answering
the front door,
getting the morning paper,
or going to the supermarket,
it's just kind of creepy.
The second problem with robes?
Imagine you go to sign
for room service at the hotel,
and all of a sudden
your privates are now public.
Not exactly the kind of public
offer you had in mind,
huh, Kevin?
In over 200 years, men's robes
have barely changed at all,
so I redesigned and
re‐engineered the bath robe
into something guys today
would actually want to wear.
Introducing DudeRobe,
the most badass robe‐and‐lounge
wear you have ever seen.
DudeRobe is a
mix‐and‐match collection
of four dude‐friendly pieces.
There's the robe, the hoodie,
pants, and shorts.
Each piece contains comfy
and absorbent towel lining
on the inside, to soak up
wet and sweat,
and premium sweatcher
material on the outside,
to give it that
streetwear vibe.
It's loungewear you can
even wear out of the house,
and instantly go from
"creep" to "chic".
[ Laughter ]
It's perfect for
after the shower,
after the beach, after working
out, after shooting hoops,
or just hanging out
on a regular Sunday.
DudeRobe's got you
covered everywhere.
Look, there are two kinds
of guys in the world ‐‐
guys who wear robes,
and guys who wouldn't
be caught dead in them.
DudeRobes are
actually for both.
Now, which one of you Sharks
wants to step out of the tank,
and into something
way more comfortable?
My butler, Jeeves, over here
has some samples to hand out,
so you can see and feel
why DudeRobe
is the only robe
a dude should ever wear.
So, we only have four.
There's one of each piece,
so if you guys can share
that would be great.
John: Why do you have
only four pieces?
Just curious.
In terms of having samples,
I launched three months ago.
I did a Kickstarter campaign.
There have definitely been
some manufacturing issues
that I'm working out.
Greiner:
So, Howie, I'm curious ‐‐
what's your background,
and how did you get to
DudeRobe becoming your life?
So, my first year
of law school
I started negotiating
NFL contracts,
and during law school,
I, you know,
was building an agency.
So, in 1996 or '7,
I get a call from a guy
who was working out of
his grandmother's basement,
and he asked me if I could do
a contract for him and I said,
"Sure, no problem",
and negotiated the deal,
and he said,
"You know,
I could pay you
the few thousand dollars
that I owe you,
but cash is kind of tight,
would you be willing
to take some equity?"
My son had just been born.
My wife said, "Listen,
we need the money.
You don't know where this
company is going to end up",
and that was Under Armour,
and it was Kevin Plank
who called me.
Oh, wow.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Really?
Yep.
Did you take the equity
from Kevin?
Uh, no, I did not.
[ All groaning ]
I'm just wondering, what's
that equity worth today
that you didn't take?
Probably about
$250,000,000 or so?
‐Oh, my God.
‐Yippie‐ki‐yay.
[ Laughs ]
Alright, it's a hell
of a story, Howie, okay?
Thank you.
But at the end
of the day,
you're in the
fleecewear business,
and that's a very
competitive space,
and you've kind of combined
a bunch of elements
into DudeRobe.
I'm not saying it
doesn't have merit,
but I'm thinking to myself,
if I want any of this stuff,
how are you going to get to me,
what's the plan to market it?
You understand these
problems, because...
Sure.
...you're in the most
competitive
clothing category
there is.
The thing is,
looking at you,
it looks like, you know, just
shorts and a hoodie.
You could get those ‐‐
‐Nooo.
Well, you can, but these
are lined with towel,
and that's ‐‐ and that's
the thing about them.
I work out.
‐So the only difference is,
it's lined with fleece?
That's a distinction
without a difference.
Let me back up a little,
and let me tell you
what I've done with it, so far.
I've launched the Kickstarter
in June, okay?
So, I was asking for $25,000.
We ended up doing
just over $65,000.
What sold the most?
I offered a full set.
That sold the most,
which shocked me.
This ‐‐ this
outfit here?
The full set.
O'Leary: And what
did you sell it for?
The full set
was $219.
Oh!
You sell that for $219?
The ‐‐ I mean, there are robes
that sell for $100
to, I just saw
one for $220.
Howie, when you look at it,
it looks like sweatshirt ‐‐
pull‐over sweatshirt ‐‐
with sweatpants.
Right. Right.
It's like, if I want the same
thing, I just go to Target
and pick up a pull‐over
sweatshirt.
Right. Right, but ‐‐
The quality's nice, but there's
no way for anyone to know
until they get
their hands on it.
So, for those reasons
I'm out.
Okay.
Fair enough.
Howie, just out
of interest,
what does your wife
think of this idea?
She ‐‐
She actually loves it.
Then I'm going
the other way. I'm out.
[ Laughter ]
The thing for me,
where I'm hung up here ‐‐
besides the fact
that it looks to me
like stuff
you could get anywhere,
I find guys are usually
really hot all the time,
so you put on something
like this, and it's heavy,
and I feel like it
should be lightweight,
as opposed to heavyweight,
and for those reasons, I'm out.
Thank you.
Howie, I respect that you've
taken something out there.
You're farther ahead than
most people watching at home.
I've invested in stuff
I don't understand,
and done really well
with it.
This one ‐‐
I don't understand.
You don't? Okay.
I don't get the butler.
I don't get the robe.
It looks like
a sweatshirt.
Like, what you're
wearing.
Yeah?
It looks like something every
guy wears on a Saturday ‐‐
Intentionally.
No, I got it, but I don't get
where you're going with it.
I'm out.
Daymond, you should be
all over this.
This is your space.
John:
One place in goods you never
want to be in the middle.
You want to be in the high‐end,
you want to be in the low‐end.
Sleepwear, generally ‐‐
you want to go and buy
your Versace, Gucci.
If not, you're going
to go to places
like Burlington
and T. J. Maxx.
This is in the middle,
and you never want
to become pressed
in the middle,
so I just think that this is
going to be a challenge for you,
and I'm out.
‐All the best, Howie.
‐Thank you.
‐And good luck, Howie.
Busch:
I think they missed out on it.
I guess they didn't really get
where we were going with it.
Hopefully, they'll
look back and say,
"We missed out on this one",
just like I missed out
on Under Armour, you know.
That's how it goes.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a brand
for an under‐served market.
♪♪
Oh, my.
That's some
long‐ass hair.
Yo, Sharks.
I'm Lindsay Barto,
a.k.a.
El Moreno.
And I'm Chris Healy,
better known as El Rubio.
We're from San Diego,
California.
We're seeking $95,000
in exchange
for a 10% equity stake
in our business,
The Longhairs, a men's
grooming‐and‐lifestyle brand
and global fraternity
for men with long hair.
Kevin's out.
Do you know
what Genghis Khan‐‐
I may grow my hair
back for this deal.
Do you know what Genghis Khan,
Louis XIV,
and Benjamin Franklin
all had in common?
They were longhairs.
In fact,
45 of the 53 framers of
the Constitution had long hair,
and the ones who
didn't wore a wig,
so people thought
they did.
You know who else was born
to be a longhair?
[ Laughter ]
Now Lori, I know we all can't
have as perfect hair as you,
but you know what?
We sure can try.
Healy: So, Sharks, if you
could be so kind
as to place the wig
upon your skull,
adjust it accordingly.
Mr. Wonderful, to take you back
to those glory days.
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yes. Mark, just
looking fantastic.
‐There it goes.
‐Feels normal.
‐Guys, alright.
‐Phenomenal.
Now that we are all feeling
the flow, let us tell you
a little bit about
our flagship product.
So Sharks, have you ever asked
a man for a hair tie?
No.
You know why?
Because it wasn't cool,
until now.
Now you can get hair ties
for guys...
and guess what?
Now it is cool.
Hair Ties for Guys
are freaking awesome,
so tie it up with pirates,
the American flag,
and lightning bolts, which show
that you mean business.
They tell you my hair ties are
as epic as these flowing manes.
‐Yeah!
That's right, Sharks.
We are The Longhairs,
and we advocate, educate,
and celebrate
men's long manes
with hair whips and high‐fives,
and we are looking
for the right Shark
to invest in this untapped,
niche market that's about
to go supernova!
So, who's ready to ride
with The Longhairs,
and turn this flow
into dough?
Wow.
So, Sharks, please go ahead,
and open the boxes now.
You're going to find
our Hair Ties for Guys,
as well as a couple
of our other products.
This is what?
Hair serum.
A specially formulated
argan oil.
Shiny, plus a little
condition effect.
Robert, I see that it was
a little bit challenging
doing this for
your first time.
Are you saying you don't
like my man bun?
No, you look fantastic!
Look at that.
Oh, my God.
He looks like a freaking
Hamilton reject.
‐That is phenomenal.
‐Alright.
Are you selling
any of this stuff?
We are.
Well, let's talk
about that.
Alright, so year
one was last year.
We did $25,000
in sales.
Year to date, this year,
we're at $85,000.
‐Whoa.
‐Wow.
We're on pace
for $140,000.
Where are you
selling headbands?
We have two channels
right now ‐‐
our website and Amazon,
and that's it.
So, it's all margin.
That's even better.
Yeah, oh, yeah.
What do you
sell it for?
What's your margin?
So, that collect‐‐
the packs
you're holding there,
we're selling for $12.
You sell this for $12?!
Correct.
What does it cost
you to make?
$1.60.
And what's your
women's equivalent?
Ah, so there's a‐‐
Really cheap.
Wide range ‐‐
it goes from $2 for, like,
a pack of 100, really.
Why wouldn't I just, you know,
steal my wife's?
That's what we'd been doing,
and really,
we started growing
our hair out
for the first time,
and we started going
and buying hair ties at
the women's hair care aisle.
And we're figuring out,
okay, these are pink,
these are polka dot,
these are purple.
Like, I just want
black regular.
So you're saying the colors
aren't manly?
Right.
It's the colors,
but it's also
the conditioning...
Manly.
and what we actually
found out
through our product testing
and development
is we actually have come up
with a superior hair tie.
Why are they better?
The problem that we were
able to solve
in developing
these hair ties
is that brands were not
able to print robust,
creative designs on the
outside of the hair tie
without sacrificing
performance,
so we're able to use
a polyester‐based elastic blend
that allowed us
to do a heat‐transfer
so that we could print
all the designs that we wanted
without sacrificing
the performance,
and we've also used
this sleeve to cover the seam,
which allows us to individually
brand all the hair ties.
So, now that it's the best
hair tie in the world,
would women buy it?
Absolutely.
It's a fun
little business.
I give you guys credit, man,
and it's a good angle.
Is there anybody else
focused on guys with long hair?
There's really no one
speaking to
men with long hair
or certain‐‐
Where'd you get that?
There's no one selling
specific products
to men with long hair.
Hey, Chris,
why did Mark get‐‐
Is this from my hair?
Uh, we tried to dye your hair,
because it was ‐‐
Now you tell me!
Come on, dude!
‐Oh, my God!
‐Why did you dye his hair?
Because it was actually
a red wig.
‐Is it coming off right now?
‐It's red, and you dyed it!
‐I love it.
‐Why did you do this?
This is what happens
when you dye your hair.
‐Is it coming off on you?
‐Wow!
‐Okay, so ‐‐
‐Oh, my God!
How do you guys
get the word out now?
We have a podcast,
articles.
We have videos.
Cue it up.
This is El Rubio attempting
to break the most consecutive
hair whips in
the Grand Canyon.
[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, my God.
‐Chris, is that you?
Yeah.
How many did you do?
14 consecutive days.
‐What?!
‐14 consecutive days?
We wanted to beat
a world record.
John: In the Grand Canyon,
whipping your hair?
When ‐‐
how many whips?
We weren't counting the actual,
individual whips.
It was the days in a row.
Okay. But how many
guys have hair
down to their shoulders
or longer?
So, what we know is
that we've captured
close to 5,000
customers so far.
We know we're getting 45,000
unique visitors every month.
O'Leary: Okay, guys ‐‐
I like you and I like this.
Let me throw a deal out here
because I want to be
a part of this movement.
What?!
'Cause you guys make crazy
margins, so here's my offer.
I'm going to give you your
$95,000 for 10%.
However, if I've ever seen
a deal
that could support
a royalty, this is it.
So, here's how I get
my dough back,
because 10% is nothing.
You know what I mean?
So, I want two bucks off every
order until I get back $200,000,
which basically
doubles my money.
Ugh.
Then, it goes away ‐‐
That's ‐‐
And I keep my ‐‐
Silence, please.
Then I keep my 10%
as your partner
to give me an incentive
to keep blowing up your website,
because when I get
behind this, guys with hair,
and even guys without hair, are
going to be ordering this thing.
Uh, Kevin,
that's a generous offer.
We appreciate it,
first of all...
Of course it is!
...that you would
believe in us ‐‐
I totally
believe in you.
Having just met us
for a minute here.
We'd like to consider
a little bit further.
So, to me, looking at
what you're doing,
with those ties
and the headbands,
I'd be doing a lot of black,
I'd do skull‐and‐crossbones,
I would do things like that,
that are just
a little bit more edgy,
because I do feel that guys
are going to gravitate
to that more.
Lori, it's not
the Recommendation Tank.
You're recommending
them to death.
Are you going to
make an offer?
Are you investing?
I ‐‐ No.
Well, there you have.
I did not see his ‐‐
All that noise.
‐We're listening, Lori.
‐Lori, what's the word?
For me, I would be redesigning
everything that you had,
which, I'm sure,
that you don't want that.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
And you are so rude!
So rude!
Okay, guys, before you get back
to the king of Propecia,
here's my thought ‐‐
we all work here,
I believe, to have
a quality of life,
and I don't know
if you need my investment,
because if I call
you on the phone
and find out you've been
whipping your hair
in the Grand Canyon for 14 days,
we're going to have a problem.
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to destroy
your quality of life.
I'm out.
I like you, guys, right?
Because you know
what you're doing.
Yep.
Alright, so
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you
$100,000 for 25%.
‐Expensive.
‐What?
Well, you realize, Kevin gave
you an offer a long time ago.
What was your offer,
Kevin?
Very, very
reasonable,
given that Mark's going to steal
a quarter of your business.
I said I'd give you the $95,000
you asked for.
I'll take the 10% equity
to get involved,
but I want $2 from every order
until I get back $200,000.
And that royalty goes away.
That's how I get
my capital back.
But then, we're still left with
our friendship and our hair,
but I only have 10% of
the company versus his 25%.
I like my deal
a lot better.
Lindsay, you got two
completely different offers.
They asked you ‐‐
What do you guys
want to do?
You guys know I'm not
patient, right?
Mark, would you do it
for 15%, $100,000?
I'd do it for 20%.
Yes or no?
‐Do the royalty deal.
‐Kevin.
♪♪
Mark ‐‐ we got a deal.
‐Done!
‐Yeah!
Mark, man,
we're going for you.
Let's go, buddy.
‐Oh, yeah.
‐Come on, let's get them.
Let's go.
‐Aw.
‐Whoo!
Barto:
Struck a deal with the big dog.
One guy we were really eyeing.
We thought
he would get it.
We're in business
with Mark Cuban.
Whoo!
Aw, dude.
♪♪